they're cycling but not exactly they
have this recurrent behavior right
and uh of course you know whenever
you know somebody asks you to try to
prove something okay
you're looking for something that can
help you prove this
okay so we're looking for a kind of
theorem that says like look if
conditions a b c are met
then
like something like this is true
okay right so let's try to see once us
theorem okay
all right so this is a
okay arguably one of one of the most uh
famous theorems in uh
dynamical systems and ergodic theory
it's full the poincare recurrence
of the point area was actually proving
the
in 1890
okay so parker exactly characterized
which systems
have this property of recurrence
that now follows his name
and he says
you effectively need two
conditions okay
so the first condition is actually
relatively trivial it says that it
better be the case if you're trying to
prove that something like
cycles and goes back to itself
it better be the case that your orbits
are bounded otherwise your orbits can
can you know escape to infinity like
game over there's nothing to prove okay
the first thing uh the first condition
is number two the second condition is
actually rather non-trigger
it says like okay um
this your dynamical system okay now now
if you do
know
not as a function from a point to point
okay
but you can view it as a function from a
set to a set okay so take the set
take all of these points map them to
their respective points and now you have
the map of the set okay
and now we want that uh
this dynamic preserves volume okay so
for the for the current you know for the
day stock only thick volume just think
of like the back measure okay the
standard notion of
high dimensional euclidean volume okay
and then he says like okay as long as
these two
conditions are satisfied then recurrence
is necessary
and
here is a
yeah
it's a very very powerful theorem okay
and it has like a very very simple super
elegant proof again
the the
the proof the sketch of the proof is the
following
okay so
yeah so
well first of all like
why okay let's let's imagine we have
such a map
and i take this the set of points that
correspond to this uh you know joystick
whatever and i move it forward according
to dynamic
again because the dynamic preserves
volume in 3d space
this thing will move to another position
let's say in this room this is bound in
this room the orbits so this is its um
shape can change it can become like this
but these volumes has to be exactly the
same
so now because it's it's bounded you
cannot escape this room
we have a clear upper bound
on the number of of iterations
before it actually has to intersect some
of its prematures
it's the volume of the room divided by
the volume of this joystick correct
so that's the fact that it will
intersect itself at some point some
pretty much
is trivial
what is less trivial is why can it not
somehow intersect in something like that
fold like a letter roll
okay
so ghost goes goes goes good but it
doesn't intersect where it started
is what i would need to show that this
thing is recurrent but it just turns
back into itself and say it goes
here okay
here's the proof of he's a genius of
poncare she's like hey
i will prove that it's not possible
remember
we said that the system preserves volume
for all possible sets
okay
so here's my choice of set it's going to
be the union of this
plus this plus this
plus this plus this
1 2 3 4
5.
if each of them has volume a
by volume preservation this has volume
5a
but now the set
if you take its forward image this goes
here
this goes here this goes here this goes
here this goes here
so this disappears
so 5 a become 4a
impossible
so
that's the proof with a little bit of it
is a proof if if i only allow you to
somehow measure volume in discrete cells
like like a little like pixels like a
little bit of like translating this to
measure theory is actually the proof
okay
and then uh yeah and the fact that you
have to account for like zero measure is
exactly because of this approximation
right of that that when you have like
continuous space you cannot account for
zero measure sets
uh returning back themselves
okay so that's the proof and what's
really amazing okay about the theorem is
that like you can actually see it in
practice
so i will describe you a very simple
actually algebraic uh technique theorem
that allows you to detect
for any map if the map somehow preserves
some volume okay and now here
i i um yeah if you think about this like
what is an image an image is a is a
bunch of numbers you know
like you say whatever you have 60 by 60
pixels or something or 600 by 600 right
and then you have like for each such
pixel you have three different numbers
so rgb okay
so this is uh
600 by 600 times 3
to the r
so any picture is actually a point in
this in this
uh euclidean space okay so now what i
can do is i can create a transformation
that takes points in space
and possess volume staying in the space
so so this case transformation it tells
you like give me a picture i'll give you
another picture
of course this transformation is it's
just a mathematical artifact so it just
creates garbles
garbles like mess immediately okay but
what does the theorem tell you keep
iterating
at some point you have to get
arbitrarily close to where you started
from
and here you can you can visually see it
again
that's extremely powerful
all right so
okay
all right so that's the theorem okay so
our goal is again
apply the theorem so
here's the three steps step one the
system produces volume step two
proofs of how the vectors are bounded
step three uh apply pancreatic currents
uh okay now
it seems actually that that step two is
trivial because
the trajectories you know the
probability distributions they're just
product of synthesis everything is
bounded okay
but the way we're going to prove this
is going to prove this after a change of
variables
and when we do the change of variables
to make this step easy
this now will become unbounded
so we have to we have to deal with that
okay
so yeah
okay
um
and here's the tools that we're gonna
use
so as i said um this the first part
actually
would be something trivial so do that
will give us another very famous very
powerful theorem okay
from uh again for dynamical systems
but uh verifying it
that that
this game theory dynamics you know
preserve volume will actually not even
use any math you could it would just
fall immediately and actually this holds
for all games
not just your sound games
so remember yesterday when i told you
like look you cannot find any mixedness
equilibrium
that is that's an attractor
it's because this theorem holds for all
games
again
so if the dynamics are like
incompressible then you cannot you
cannot
squeeze the equilibrium and make it uh
and make an attraction okay all right so
then
this actually would become okay so if
this holds for all games
then step two must be very special for
zero sum games otherwise the theorem
would hold all dynamics should be
cycling okay
and that's the idea here is like uh
you know in order to show that your
energy somehow does not go to infinity
you you show that this dynamic has
something like energy conservation
and uh this energy conservation
in a very somehow like fitting sense
remember
the regularizer for replicator is what
is entropy okay
so it has to do of course in sound
entropy information theory right
so the invariant
will be
a notion of distance
that makes sense
in information space so it won't be
euclidean distance it will actually be
the scale back uh quebec libra
divergence which a notion of like a
national pseudo it's a pseudometer it's
not exactly a metric but it's a notion
of distance between distribution okay
so if
uh yeah okay so for example if you use
the euclidean regularizer then the
distance actually here would be included
in distance and so forth but we won't go
into those details
okay so that's a
that's a two-step process okay i just
like you will hear them very very
very very nice
um okay so
you will exactly characterize which
systems when systems are are locally
somehow compressing themselves or
locally expanding or when they're like
flat when they're like volume preserving
and this actually has to do with what is
known as the divergence of a vector
field
so what's a vector field
as the name suggests
or just uh
you know you have some space
right and you assign like uh directions
of movement so think of this like okay
like this like well how's the wind is
moving right on every single uh point
let's say
right
right
so this is uh
so this is a function that that has
let's say maybe we're in 3d space
so it has like three different arguments
you watch your speed in direction x your
speed direction y your speed direction z
right and this of course depends on all
the positions in your 3d space
all right so this is what a is a vector
field right
now when you have this function you can
take this notion of derivative but now
the derivative because it's a is a it's
not a scalar
the the notion of over here is a
jacobian so you take all partial
derivatives right so you take the
derivative okay all right so
and what
derivative of x
with x you know all possible nine
combinations okay
but the trace which is the sum of
diagonal elements
okay
of of this uh jacobian is exactly what
controls
where the system expands or contracts
okay
so specifically
the system is is is uh
with that volume if and only if it's
divergence free so if this quality is
equal to zero okay
now i don't want you just to remember
this as a
automatically as a factor i told you i
actually want to try to prove this to
you together in the case where the
system is one-dimensional
okay
suppose that the system is
one-dimensional
what does actually mean we have only ux
right and this is a function of x
okay so now great jacob is derivative so
what this actually means is that like
okay
ux dot
of x is equal to zero
what does it actually mean it means that
your this is always constant
right so now what
volume preservation mean volume in one d
is
length right
so take any
interval of length l and that's like a
little drain
so it moves
it stays constant okay now if you go
into the into
d
like you can have like exponential
somehow expansion in one direction and
this could be counteracted by
exponential
contraction in that direction
and that's exactly what this exponents
are exactly what's being captured by
these elements so as long as these
things cancel out you're good to go
and you don't have to worry about higher
determinants because you're in
differential equation now where
everything is moved
okay that's the proof
again fundamental theorem but simple in
its it's uh
risky ideas okay
all right now i'm going to apply it and
it would be great because i won't even
do any mathematics you will just like
follow through
okay
so the idea
as you remember about um
let's see if there are dynamics which is
a special case of the
of replicator is that like look uh
actually instead of keeping track of the
probability distributions the real game
is happening on the on the payoff vector
so remember the
or the accumulative payoff vector so i
play rock paper scissors huh
so i want the total payoff for playing
rock so far the total pair for playing
scissors either player for playing uh
whatever
the third strategy
and then you take inner product minus
the regularizer and drag max okay so as
long as i can remember this
i can always compute my mixed writing
okay so this is what i'm gonna track
in my dynamical system
and actually
i'm gonna do something more
i'm gonna do a little bit somehow a
shift right so remember the inner
product
of x comma y
minus the regularizer
right so this does not
does not change if you subtract some so
like all one times some constant
okay so that's what i'm doing here i'm
taking one of the entries
and i am i am somehow like removing it
uh
and then this is actually going to be
the state space
so the state space is like you remember
for every agent every agent keeps in
mind says like look i'm going to have my
benchmark strategy it's going to be rock
for every other strategy for paper i'm
saying like how much money more money
have i made when i played paper versus
rock
and then caesar's restaurant and this
information
is is all i need to know
it's fully informative and it's exactly
what i need to know okay so that's going
to be my space unfortunately as i told
you
this can go to minus 50 plus infinity
right i play this game forever maybe i
make a lot of games okay
so
all right
but i don't care about any of these
things
all i care about is computer is quantity
now i want you
to figure out why these parties deliver
this
have to be equal to zero
okay what let's let's read this together
what is that i
i'm clear i i'm the raw player again and
i'm saying like this is total utility
for playing rock munch totality for
playing
paper okay
the time derivative of this
is my instantaneous utility for plane
rock
minus my instantaneous utility for
playing scissors
right now okay and now i'm saying like
how does this
depend
on
infinitesimal changes of my behavior
this is the same player i
let me do this again so this is my
utility for player i
for playing lock
okay so this is a prime comma x minus i
so i need to know the behavior of one of
the other agents
okay
minus
the utility for playing for playing
scissors
x minus five
okay i'm saying why did you did this
partial delivery
probably in your playing xi role
it's a different expected things from
some player i be doing to fix the eyes
of his
it's like how does it depend on what i
mean
it's independent
if i play rock
this is just this is just a function so
let's do this
so we have two players player x and
player y
the infinity of playing eyes
is just a function of y
performing your opponent's behavior
right
and this is also like just a function of
only your opponent's behavior so how
does it impact you doesn't happen at all
you've already made your decision
the only good controller you have
already you have already played it
so you don't exist at all in this
function
so this automatically cancels out for
all games
oh so this is just a game theory
there's no algebra there's nothing this
is zero
four
okay that's the proof
did you use that
sorry where did you use the fgr so
so the xtrm is used
right on the fact that
uh
yeah on the formula
uh that you could imagine okay that's a
good question so think of if you do
optimism
right
so optimism actually
like
what you play
will actually affect you
right
like so if you have like trends
somehow right so this would affect the
dynamics of like volume
volume compressing or volume
uh shrinking okay
so that's that's the thing yeah so since
any momentum
exactly yes exactly exactly and that's
what we never
mean
sometimes we do want to make dynamics
volume shrinking and actually actually
we will prove this so you can actually
formally prove
that optimism is not going to shrinking
okay so that's
another way of arguing about the
stability
i can actually get we'll get to this but
uh this has to do with discretization
techniques
okay so we're done uh with step on one
step two
okay trajectories are bounded
um
the situations are bounded okay so
okay i will tell you this okay okay this
is not easy to see
but suppose uh
yeah
but if somebody gave you this
right
so somebody tell you i'm gonna tell you
this i'm gonna i'm gonna be god i'm
gonna be kind to you and the way you
somehow you're trying to imagine a
yapuno function i'm gonna give you this
function i'm telling you this this is
this remains constant for all time
okay
then using this
this condition
you can actually prove that this y's
cannot go to plus or minus infinity
because
uh if you
meaning if that if your divergence is
constant it means that you remain you
may you stay bounded from the boundary
if uh this is a fully mixed strategy
if you go towards the boundary with this
point then this goes to infinity
so the fact that this is constant from
the summation of these positive
quantities are constant you must means
that both players will stay
bound away from the boundary and this
implies in the in the z space
that you stay you stay bounded
okay so that's it of course you have to
i mean sometimes that's a little bit of
the thing that you have to
try to
be lucky in some sense
and uh find something that can allow you
to control the space and as i said this
only holds for zero time games it's very
very special
okay so
and in the case of ftr dynamics
effectively if you have
some version of beckman divergence
see i want to go into the details but
some some reasonable generalization of
this notion for different type of
regularizer
okay so that's it
in the previous slide i'm still a bit
confused yes
on the board
you have there
the derivative with respect to your
choice x the probability
yeah okay so you have a derivative with
respect to the payoffs
over here you have the derivative yeah
okay so here
i just made the argument in the
probability space so here you actually
do it in the in the payoff space but it
doesn't really matter the main thing is
like
as long as this depends on i
right
then this you have no control
over this difference
see that you see what i'm saying
so this there's a one-to-one
relationship between these variables and
x
okay so in some sense it's a it's
another equivalent way of representing
that information
i'm saying this information is totally
irrelevant for this plan
but then why did you not do it in that
space like what what
just because
yeah because it was not clear for
somebody that
like i think grant had the discussion
like oh yeah why
i think it's i think it's easier to see
in this space that
here this depends on why right
and then i think the argument no i'm
saying why in on the slide you have it
what is more convenient to do in this
space uh
because it's actually not true
in the other space
so like you have to okay
all right so the arguments here remember
so the
right
okay so in this space we are in rn
again so you will still works in our end
if you work on a subspace then you have
to be much more careful what you mean by
volume okay
okay
so you have to have like a more
complex notion of a volume form and this
this change of variables actually
simplifies the analysis
you could still do it in the original
space but then as i said like it's more
pedantic to define what volume means
yeah thanks that's actually a good
question
uh
okay
all right so and then okay the main
thing is that like i said the fun thing
is the simulations you know you've
proven all these things and now you just
sit back and you see like okay let's
test the power of the theorem
all right so here's
this uh
uh the transformed space remember the
transforms this is like matching penis
so there are transform spaces for the x
player how much more have i gotten for
playing rock reverse playing uh for
playing heads versus tales
so if you have at zero
i'm i'm going to output 50 50. okay this
is the nas equilibrium
so if you have exactly the same payoffs
historically you're gonna output so this
is the nas okay and this is somehow like
okay look uh
like you know
i've gotten more more money for playing
heads more money for playing tails for
the other person whatever okay so now
i'm gonna say like we're going to move
this forward
and this should preserve volume
okay
and in some sense okay of course it does
uh but the interesting thing is that
like okay you have this deformation
so it's not like that uh so the set gets
spaghettified
as it's actually being being uh
uh
somehow moved around
and the reason for this actually this
the behavior of this game is very very
simple because
because it's just two-dimensional
in two-dimensional space effectively all
the only allowable economic behaviors
are very distinct
so what happens is like uh here there's
a bunch of periodic orbits
around the nasa equilibrium for every
possible different level sets but now
the things that they have different
speeds
okay locally so as a result like things
get gets
deformed
uh over time and
and you get more and more like stretched
out it actually goes for a little while
so maybe we're gonna wait so
so in some sense if you waited for long
enough this would just like
somehow create an infinitely thin dense
like string that somehow like covers the
whole range of allowable
energy levels okay but again as you see
you stay bound away from the boundary
which is the first guarantee and nothing
escapes infinity
okay
so if you see that
and you buy that again at this point
that this thing could produce volume
then
you have recurrence
and okay you see like look i don't
really
believe that this thing preserves volume
you can actually go all the way
and uh mechanically
use you know some voronoi diagram
approximation
to actually
compute the volume so this is again a
different visualization so this is
the level sets so different colors
correspond to a different energy so
every point stays on the same
color here but remember you started
you started with just this square
okay so everything's like this perfect
uh geometry
but it just gets again
deformed
but as you see
the in the kl sense it just moves
forward and backward
so points do not actually change
change their energy
as i said like this is really about this
like look you can actually
you can actually test
the the theorems to their full extent
okay
and that's it okay so
during the figure the volume was
increasing
which figure
your volume seems to be so this is okay
so this i mean
or is it oh it's the
okay yes this yeah okay yeah
i mean i don't know like for a moment i
thought like wow like
like like vasilis really has like
immense supervision
yeah like uh you know uh yeah
no i think this is like uh i mean it's
not perfect i mean there are always some
numerical issues with any approximation
right but but no i think this is uh as
good as it gets
all right so then the other thing is
like once you have like energy
preservations like you know and and you
you have some bags in physics things
start like twinkling
he said like oh look uh
you know the most famous
class of energy preserving systems
called the hamiltonian
okay which i mean
okay this
standard uh
somehow like systems we have like
position momentum pair these are like
dual variables and you have a set of
equations that immediately imply that
this function is being preserved
well there is a way to
reformulate the system somehow in a way
that
you actually make it a formal
hamiltonian
okay and uh in some sense the
the hamiltonians like uh
you know
the convex conjugates
which is something coming from convex
analysis the thing that's like that that
becomes your your energy
uh yeah and and this is something that
was explored before
uh all the way back from 96 but these
arguments actually extend to more
general uh regularizers
okay so yeah so there's something deep
about the connection with physics is not
just uh
at the base level okay
and now it's like okay now actually
we're done
we're done with uh
we'll continue starting
um how am i doing this time
okay okay good good
with uh okay so
this is a really discreet time
okay and now we're going to think about
digitization but are there any questions
about the continuous time
analysis
yes
would the volume necessarily have to be
stable if the space in which the
probability density
set was also changing directly related
to the volume so that the space grew in
the direct proportions of the volume so
that your setting actually oscillates so
here okay i haven't talked about what we
everything's actually set right now you
could you could do what you're saying
and i said like we have done that but
like it's not really
so
troublesome the last slide
[Music]
dynamics is for me okay great great
that's that's a very valid question okay
so the thing about
um yeah the thing about hamiltonian
systems is that like that from the
perspective of the customs theory they
have they have uh somehow attracted much
much more attention than any random
class of dynamical systems okay so if
you can reformat the system as a
hamiltonian so maybe there's extra tools
you can also get for free just like okay
the theme says okay for any system if
your computer has this property then
this actually holds holds so then all
have to do is like testing okay
like oh is this properly true in this
system
okay so that's like that's generally
like a
like a like a viable property and this
actually some remove leverage
in this discretization approach
okay
okay yeah so for example yes so let me
tell you this okay so so okay
hamiltonians is really somehow like uh
planetary orbits planetary mechanics
okay so people have exhaust have spent
insane amount of energy actually like
their understands was developed to be
able to predict accurately the orbits
emotion okay so people have developed
you know
insane
many many different digitizations with
very very high accuracy
scientifically that's just this is usual
right it's about simulating the system
correct yes but is it but is it uh
desirable
not from the perspective of analysis but
from the perspective of like the
dynamics itself that
the dynamic behavior in the game should
have a hamiltonian or maybe it's better
if it doesn't and it can register or i
don't know like you know yeah
you don't care about knowledge
so yeah so here i mean
when it comes to these kind of questions
i'm like totally agnostic
so like my question is like
if i see
a behavior and system it's kind of like
recalling then okay whatever i mean
first of all don't feel like neither
positive or negative about this it's
just how the system behaves but now you
can say like look like how many donor
systems are recovering
is this
truly like somehow is there some
connection over there or is it like just
another random system that recycles from
the
movement
okay thank you
all right um
all right so now we're actually going in
discrete time and you can tell this
because now the orbits are no longer
smoother just because these dotted
points
and we're going to start of course with
the multiplicative updates
and uh so and in this case
now remember the kill divergence the
guild divergence was what
was constant that was your environment
functions right
but the reason why it was constant
because in in continuous time you can
you can disregard second order effects
again
but in in continuous time in discrete
time you cannot do it anymore
okay but because
like your orbits are effectively convex
your second order errors
like they always have like a reliable
sign
they they move away
okay
so you're always moving your way
and the question is like okay what
happens to these errors as they
aggregate
if the sum of the squares of the errors
goes to infinity then you kill that
question with infinity and you convert
the boundary and that is this case
okay
well somehow
if
this is this is something finite
then you convert to some limit behavior
okay which is like a level set of the
replicator
but what is pretty interesting is like
how in something
unpredictable
the statistics of the behavior of the
system is
right you could say like look
all i know is like you know
at some point some level set maybe all
the way the boundary or maybe anywhere
in between would be stabilized
and then the statistics
would be some distribution over these
levels
okay
so actually zero sum games from a
statistics perspective have a huge
somehow like variety of possible
behaviors that you can actually see
right it's not just a dirac distribution
at equilibrium okay
and even if you now if you change
somehow the regularizer you change the
geometry of this circle
but this is not a euclidean circle it's
a kl board
okay changing the writer will just
affect how this actually looks
so you have like all of these different
uh
yeah all of these different phenomena
like emerging
and
uh yeah
and i'm going slowly
to oh yeah now you cannot see all the
other behavior okay what happens to
volume preservation
once again second effects a real thing
and now it's actually volume expansion
so it's not just that
if i take an infinitesimal ball out of
the nas equilibrium that only this ball
expands is like no no you have expansion
everywhere
okay
so you have this kind of like
unpredictability right some small
perturbation
could actually uh have this like large
long-term effects like yeah that's
colloquially told
all the butterfly effect
and uh yeah so this is an example of of
such a behavior
so like somehow like this is
your initial set it's like a small
set and then you know you like every
iteration is like maybe like a thousand
steps or whatever
and then you see like somehow like you
have both the rotation that comes from
the first order approximation the
rotation of replicator but also like an
expansion okay that creates call like a
tornado looking kind of effects
so we've called this the
the phenomenon vortex
so yeah it's kind of i think it's kind
of cute
as a
as a behavior
and uh actually okay so so far i've only
talked about uh
deterministic dynamical systems and
indeed like once you
once you start randomness
everything should become like much
harder
um
but
at least for the case of uh
stochastic mwu
you can actually analyze what happens
and uh
what you have is that the statistical
behavior
actually concentrates only on pure
strategy outcomes
so okay i mean this is
uh yeah so this is actually a
probability distribution here right so
you start let's say with a with a dirac
measure with probability one i'm
starting here but now every time you
actually see an update room
your update rule happens because
everybody actually
threw the random coins and said like oh
now i'm gonna play sheds i'm gonna play
tails okay
so every day let's say you knocked me
procedures you have nine different
outcomes
so the probability
splits nine ways again
how it splits depends on the kind of
probability distribution right
but you see like eventually
where you end up spending most of your
time or where the com their probability
mass is concentrated so the actual
corners
which once again it's like
very far away from what you would expect
from the statistic from from the dirac
at the center you know which is the the
nasa equilibrium
uh
in the case of json games again and now
here's like an interesting question
okay what if i'm gonna get in the game
of like uh
keeping this kitten alive here
like this is not straight straight
digger's kitten this is a you know
georgious kitten or whatever and it's
like i don't want to be deformed or at
least it can be deformed but like at
least i need volume to stay constant
uh can i can i somehow like do that
and yeah and then uh
you can actually develop
a discretized method
that does this
and actually uh
like vasily this is where connections to
hamiltonians come into play
so
in this paper we're actually
uh proven that this uh alternating
grading sensor like i play you play i
play you play okay
so
so this has uh this recurrent property
and it has actually a bunch of other
very nice properties okay
actually this uh okay importantly these
theorems only holds for the case of
unconstrained
uh bilinear games okay so here there's
no simplex again this is an important
simplification if you are simplex like
all of these theorems will actually
collapse okay but as long as you're
willing to say like okay look this is
like you know when something feels more
like machine learning learning inspired
okay
then you have all of these properties
you have taken the properties of
replicator
of the continuous time okay
but uh right
so
and and the other thing that's actually
interesting
is uh i think somebody asked me about
this they're like okay now you have a
different notion that of energy that's
been preserved
so in the case of continuous time the
for for gradient descent
your energy is actually the the radius
okay
here it's more like an ellipsoid
like this there is an error term that
you have to add
okay on this on your original energy
function but once you add it then you
can actually show that
this
slightly perturb energy
is
is uh preserved but that's fine because
this is guarantees to show you that that
uh
you cannot go to infinity
and then you can you can proceed with uh
with the proof of la poncare
okay so that's the
that's the idea
and then okay i will i will i'll just
touch upon this because uh because this
did a great job
uh explaining about all of this uh
results about optimistic and uh variance
of course like
certain work here without vasilis of
course it's been a lot this is like kind
of like really really
old by now there's a lot of like uh
very exciting recent work
okay but there's another way of
interpreting this as i said these are
like look
actually optimism is volume shrinking
okay but here's the interesting thing
this doesn't come for free
optimism is volume shrinking in zero sum
games
but if you flip the utility design of
the second agent it becomes expanding
so it's kind of like okay like there's
no freelance theorem okay if you don't
have you'll be great okay look i can
optimize all
nash okay
and uh you know at least optimism does
not do it i mean it's not clear that any
any algorithm actually does it we know
that
you know as i said yesterday fd avail
cannot cannot uh
cannot make anything attractive right
it's it's you cannot you cannot create a
antiox equilibrium so this is
yeah so this is something like that's
really really really open
outside the special but very important
case of of zeros and games okay and of
course i should point out that there's a
lot of very exciting work in this on the
space of like you know zero sum games
was like non-convex concave but then
again you know because this did an
excellent job expanding upon this
results so uh so here we won't be
exploring those
yes
sorry
oh yeah yeah so here the results
actually are in discrete time
it is and that that is in our paper
it's just it's a stepping stone in the
proof okay but i don't want to go
i don't want to go in that direction
right now but yes if you answer this
question yeah please uh check out this
uh paper
okay so so human here's like in my my
one shot one slight summary of
everything that we've heard so far okay
look in the case of james and games like
computer dynamics just behave as
pendulums okay and maybe i'm going to
say that okay uh i mean this is
interesting
i don't if
idealized
is the correct work i'm seeing like they
say okay whatever like uh i don't feel
good or bad about it that's the state of
the world
for whatever reason continuous time
dynamics lead to
cycles in quotes poincare currents more
accurately okay but if you if you
understand that
then you should not be surprised that
discretization controls everything
okay if you have a system that's just
like on the verge of like not going away
or going close okay
then any second order control on the
system will totally dictate this
behavior
okay so if you're not careful you get
instability and chaos by just a natural
oily discretization
if you do more more somehow this uh
optimistic ideas where you say like okay
don't go here go into the future
so get a gradient here and just apply it
here now you're moving the interior and
then if you do some more
like alternating methods then
you okay this is horrible
yeah
so authentic method does something
effective like this
so you don't you're not exactly on this
cycle but you stay close enough
all right so that's uh
yeah so that's it i mean that's the the
case of of zero sum games any any
any questions
about uh
about the settings
okay so
i i have promised the to give you
definition of tears and then we will
we will finish with this
uh
and then we'll finish with some
something i consider to be kind of
interesting and
uh and somewhat surprising it's like
okay look um
as i said like congestion and potential
gains are the paragon of of stability
and good behavior for learning dynamics
okay so like if you look
then the amps actually converts to
equilibria in those cases and uh and in
most natural cases okay but here we're
gonna be very somehow like uh
like nasty theoreticians and you're
gonna be thinking like like uh
like you know like like i'm
[Music]
like i'm bp and i'm trying to destroy
the climate
like how much do i need to push the
system
in a very somehow like unnatural
direction
before the system actually
breaks
it performs a bifurcation and it
exhibits new kinds of behaviors okay and
then the question is like you know what
type of behaviors do you
do you see and then uh yeah
and how okay and the type of effectively
uh face transitions that we'll try to
explore is like what happens for a very
specific model of increasing the agent's
behavior
okay so can you like keep adding adding
adding adding more more agents to the
system and then at what point
in our specific model you know the
system just now says oh i can't deal
with this and the dynamics like uh run
around uh a mock
okay so
again congestion games i think we've
seen this yesterday
so again i will be using like a very
very simple
example for anything i will be talking
today
but i said like okay here's what we more
or less know
as i said like look if you want
multiplicative with updates or any other
reasonable dynamic
and your step and your learning rate is
not is small enough
then the systems are great in life okay
we know this actually don't they just
converse equilibria
that by using some sort of like a more
advanced technology
of center stable mindful theorem you can
actually show that it converts to pure
nash but the question here is that we
say like look uh let's really increase
epsilon okay
uh this is not a good idea okay
definitely for multiplicative whether
it's not a good idea but let's say for
other dynamics like maybe clairvoyant
dynamics it is a good idea so maybe you
can say like okay look let's let's start
doing this experiment and then uh
try this maybe we'll get lucky maybe we
get absolutely infinity and we see like
something really quick good it won't
happen
but it's still kind of like fun to play
around this
okay and the question is like you know
there's two questions here is like okay
is the system robust or you have uh this
phase transitions this okay
and uh yeah so let's see what happens
okay and then here's something that's
actually kind of interesting is like
okay multiplicative with updates
okay it has many many different variants
and here is like two very well known
ones so this is like the standard
approach that comes from the
from the
kkkt conditions of the of the
the regularizer but like many times
people actually say like okay look let's
let's use this linearized version when
epsilon is is small enough like oh you
know these are effectively equivalent
okay
uh so when we say like okay uh
and we'll play around with the simplest
possible
congestion game just two players to
beams okay just to keep everything like
super simple to simulate
all right
so what happens
okay so here's the here's the statements
okay
in this linear in this linearized
version
you have the most convert the most
robust is i'll ever hope brew
so for any congestion game no matter the
number of players no matter like uh you
know
number of strategies and for any epsilon
learning rates okay as long as of course
these things remain positive okay cannot
include
uh then
this dynamic will always converge to
nasa equilibrium okay which is what we
want so like this is really really great
uh what about you know
the other guy which is actually in some
sense the the original version
then things are actually very bad
uh so even the simplest possible two
balls to beans case
like uh there are simple examples that
lead to limit cycles and uh
legal tears
and in the next slide okay okay
in the next slide i will give a formal
definition
for uh for what these two words mean and
specifically legal care
but is there any question about what
what is the statement of this theorem
so this always converges
to nash
this just something really weird that
we'll see in the next slide
so okay so limit cycle is something that
like you know just
it's what you would think okay it's a
it's a it's a cycle that's a limit that
you have some initial conditions that
converge to okay so that's that's not
too exciting
of a definition
but this is exciting and it's worth
taking uh
taking a stab at this actually
this is the first
formal definition of chaos in in
mathematical literature okay
uh yeah it comes from a very similar
paper by lena york
and okay so to describe this let's
describe what the scramble said okay
so given a dynamical system
with an update rule okay f
a pair of points two points are called
scrambled
if the trajectories get arbitrarily
close
so they get super close okay but then
always move apart again
so this is like okay here's these two
points
move move move they get very very close
and then they go apart again and get
very very close and then apart but their
distance when i say they get close they
get infinitely close if you're willing
to wait long enough but they never
actually collapse into they don't like
say okay from this point we'll just join
no they always somehow like separate
again it's like a couple that's like
cannot make a decision really love each
other and then i hope shades are sorry
nice another thing
[Music]
just came up with it i feel really proud
okay i'm gonna use it again all right so
okay so this is the definition of a
scramble set
and then i'm saying oh of a scrambled
pear
a scrambled set
is like a
is a is a set of points such that any
such pair of points has this property
okay so like okay now you see if you
think about some perspective of
computation
that you cannot actually tell
any of these two
any such orbit in the set apart
because at some point they will get
within your computer accuracy
and then your computer will spit out
something and you don't know what you're
saying
okay all of these points are effectively
indistinguishable for any computational
any reasonable computational model
because this limit is equal to zero
okay so they will become
indistinguishable at some point
okay so here's the business of leader
gears
a discrete time this discrete time
a discrete time dynamical system is
called linear chaotic
if
it has periodic orbits for all possible
periods
so not just period one which is
equilibrium but po2 p3 pretty you know a
million and 11 all of them okay
and
there is an uncountably infinite loud
set that is scrambled
yes
if it
if it has period three then it has uh
you give it away
so like
you're gonna give the theorem okay so
so now it's just a definition of the
behavior
but that's that's fine it's coming so
like uh okay let's let's go let me just
jump into the theorem
because this is like totally crazy okay
so this is what this uh again this is
like one of the most similar papers
like uh in the lambda theory
linear proved that
as long as your dynamical system is one
dimensional so the simplest possible
discrete time system okay it is one
degree of freedom
as long as your orbit as long as it's a
single orbit
that's actually periodic of period three
then
it's your chaotic
so here this feels like these theorems
feel so asymmetric right so it's like
okay just
just give me
one period three
which i could do this in high school you
know you do this with like
just you know intermediate like you know
like
case analysts i give you a function f
find me if this okay this is my function
f in blue again
right so when f
intersects x equals y that's equilibrium
okay and i'm saying okay compute f
squared which is
this function okay now compute f cube
which is this function
if this f tube intersects the green line
at a point other than this
then that's part of a period three orbit
so this system
once you iterate this it's going to be
legit chaotic
so it's going to have periodic orbits of
all possible periods and
and all the other good stuff or bad
stuff
okay
so
all right so that's the idea
the idea here is like okay that that
uh
i mean you can you can see like visually
i mean the fact that that uh
as as we did in the previous example
if you want to find like a single
example or something that's video
character it's almost like you know high
school algebra to verify this just just
just finds us as a
such a case okay so that's what we
we did in this
initial paper
uh
with janice okay and then
uh there blue had like a single example
okay and you say like look this
i mean i think what was the example this
is the example this exact example
like it's linear theoretic okay and then
of course you can say like look it's
is there something magical about like
1.4
and the answer is that like
not only there's nothing magical about
1.4
but effectively okay
the only way you cannot have chaos
in this simple example
if the cosines are exactly x and x
so if the game is symmetric if so if
your equilibrium is 50 50
it's only that game
that's not gonna become chaotic okay
anything else
as you increase the step size
will
probably become character okay
yes
if you pretend this method it becomes
asymmetric so you get care yes
right uh
yeah
and
and again
um
this this theorems can also be applied
okay
so in the previous model we just have
like
effectively two agents
and instability was happening by
increasing the step size
like a mathematically equivalent model
is to have a
non-atomic population okay
and then you keep increasing somehow
like the total mass on the system okay
so this is so from the perspective of
the multiplier what updates map is like
increasing the map is like increasing
the upstream okay
and and then as i said you get chaos and
effectively you get yours for all games
so so once you prove cares for like two
games you can prove it for larger
networks by kind of like uh
not inductive kind of argument but like
you know a complex kind of like a result
okay okay something actually that sounds
kind of crazy okay
so okay so again it's chaotic the
system's chaotic so let's say i have a
last population of users and then i
cannot tell you oh this is the the
occupancies
so in the case of periodicity like all
days you're here
20 use the top link
and then even days you lose like you
know 80 and that's back and forth back
and forth
okay here's a chaotic system okay
so here like the occupancy is like
totally unpredictable okay but here's
the funny thing
in time average okay the occupancy of
its link is exactly the equilibrium cost
okay
so sometimes despite the system being
totally unpredictable
if there's somebody who observes the
statistics and say like look i'm going
to try to see like how many how many
people how much
what percentage of the population use
the top link
okay it will be exactly what equilibrium
analysis suggests okay so chaos
implements equilibrium in a weird sense
uh
yes in a weird sense okay
and then there's another thing that's
actually kind of cool yeah maybe forget
about this grass but just look here
so this is the system this is time
and this is the equilibrium level set so
when the population is small then very
quickly you convert the equilibrium
but as you keep increasing you have a
bifurcation
and you go from
period one to period two
now you have like a limit cycle of
period two
and it goes from period two to period
four
to period eight
and you have like uh this period
doubling without the cares
so the phase transitions become shorter
and shorter
okay and within a finite number of
population increase you get to care okay
but this uh
this period doubling around the chairs
has been uh
observed uh in other kind of like
dynamical systems that have to do with
the logistic equation
multiplicative bits is not in the family
of dynamics
but actually does exhibit
this kind of behavior
okay and i'm gonna finish with this
okay to get things even more weird okay
so this something like
i actually did not believe that's how it
was possible and i was like very
frustrated that it is possible and
actually provably so again here's a game
again
that has a unique equilibrium
this unique equilibrium is locally
attracting
again
and the system is still chaotic
right so like if i was an economist
and somebody told me okay like no no for
good economist i'm a guns person okay
aspiring guns person i say like look
i have a gun architecture
i have proven somehow magically that it
has a unique equilibrium okay and
furthermore
like i have proven that this is like
locally attracting
at that point like no
like this is an amazing paper like we
should go and run run with it like i'm
saying like okay look
like this is not an artificial game
this is like a congestion game it's
something that like one of the the most
natural clash of games okay and we can
create this kind of behavior
unique equilibrium locally attracting
and clear formal gear
not experimentally
provably again
so local
local stability
yeah it comes with an asterisk okay
and uh interesting enough okay so this
is shown
for follow the regularized leader so we
so this kind of behavior actually is not
possible with multiplicative word
updates
like probably it's not possible
so this actually shows it's the first
example you see like well actually look
the regularizer
which somehow like feels okay this is
like okay whatever some mathematical
detail
actually
affects the behavior of the system
in a very somehow like non-uh
non-trivial way okay
so
yeah
so there's a lot of things that we don't
understand
yeah and this is the question okay right
i've talked all about only about zero
sum games and potential games
and there's a reason about this is
because like once you go beyond this
like things become very
yeah less clear
the only thing i had what i told you
yesterday is that like look
um
yeah that that that uh
you cannot stabilize mixed knives
okay
so it doesn't matter if you play around
with the regularizer
like uh as long as the equilibrium is
not strict
then they cannot become and then you
have this this volume preservation
argument that that comes into play
okay so
yeah so i mean okay it's it's a
it's quite an active area and uh yeah
and i'm saying like okay
yeah i was discussing this uh
uh also with vasilis like you know
and i i i mean i look like
this kind of questions here should feel
like that
they are adversarial to our
exploration machine learning or ai i
think they're very like uh
synergistic okay
something like look we should like cross
fertilize ideas
so how do we you know take some of these
findings that saying in normal from
games and like maybe inspire like
algorithms for more complex
settings of games that are like are
relevant to yeah and also like vice
versa you know what kind of like incense
and ideas from ai
can actually help us uh
you know with our with our goals in most
england
oh and i think i'm
i'm pretty much done actually that's it
okay thank you
any questions
i guess i've had a conceptual question
which is how are you thinking of
dynamics are we thinking of them as ways
to analyze games we think them as
behavioral patterns of agents to kind of
figure out
is there another way that we should be
thinking about them
okay that's a that's a good question
yeah
so
yeah i'm thinking the dynamics and and
this also addressed with
how i'm trying to evolve my
almost visualization skills like i like
to be able to understand like almost
like an evolving society again
and the dynamics actually
are points in belief space
of these societies and i'm trying to
understand like how these things will
actually like evolve
and there's some very interesting
questions here that that
i think are emerging you know like uh in
terms of even uh you know representation
like the different source of randomness
you know as i said like uh
you know ideas like like entropy
comes into play
and so forth so yeah so i think that's
my that's my
way of thinking i would say but um
but i think uh yeah
different kind of interpretations uh you
know be very valued and very useful
and i would say like one thing that's
actually a very non-trivial problem and
sometimes it has been cracks in like in
the theoretical results are
visualization
like in some sense like um
many times the real breakthrough
is not any so like mathematical
technicality but what's the correct
space
like what's the correct space where you
actually study dynamics somehow it's
like like you know if you want to go
there they're out of the hamiltonians
like um
why somehow is position momentum the
correct variables
well they are
you know if somebody gives you this like
you're like halfway more than halfway
done with the problem okay
so yeah so
so yeah so uh that's insane idea
intervention question actually for
things like guns
so i think like there were like you
really have
the
the representation competition really
really explodes and you cannot hope by
any way to represent everything
the advanced equations like what you
should put out there
right you know i mean something's okay
like
like the kind of graphs that that you
know we we produce is like look
here is error error goes down you know
or like you know his performance
performance goes up okay and of course
okay but i think we and i'm not saying
this is like all super valid
important benchmarks you think but i
think it's also like
you know but i think there are probably
other things to point out there
that that uh can identify useful
structure
okay and and uh and i think that's an
interesting question to think about
right so like one of the reasons for
example guns has been like so successful
i would say as a as a
as an architecture because you can
completely plot out the face
and i said okay look i can understand
parameters
but human mind recognize faces and say
like oh my god that's amazing okay
that's a really good looking face
like let's give this my these guys more
money more energy more so it has really
made like a huge impact again
uh but now you know this idea it's
actually kind of bettering out like the
faces are already looking perfect okay
maybe this is a new kind of like uh
visualization space
that that that could be interesting and
promising
maybe something to think about
[Music]
my question about your case results is
you
the chaos results uh you wanted the
samples the population size to grow
if you're in situations that many times
arise in
ai where you have like some fixed
population
or like two you know
in guns that you were saying two agents
do you still believe that
you get this great question okay yeah
sure so like let me tell you uh
so guns you have the kind of theories
that hostile most has to do with like
volume presentation because like a pool
of tears and not you know this kind of
like uh
yeah so i don't think this this
i don't necessarily see this as a threat
for ai systems actually to be honest
like this really comes from from a
genuine
philosophical illness to me about the
state of the world
so population is increasing again and
there are systems out there like you
know traffic systems hospitals but
actually you know they're they're you
cannot create you know
physical resources
copies quickly it's not like servers you
know so somehow like okay there's a real
question like okay
do we really believe that these things
will keep working well with people just
being like self-motivated and trying to
find their own thing
and if not then maybe at some point you
actually need
a centralized authority and it's like
look you cannot go to any hospital you
want
i control where you go okay and that's
that's a very that's a very somehow like
difficult decision for many different
kinds of societies we see like people
that really value their freedom in terms
of like doing whatever you want
so i think
one question that actually that i have
is like and i'm really pursuing this is
like okay these are like really
simplified
toy models okay
can we make okay i'm always trying to
think about
like my understanding as a kind of like
set of like nesting doors okay so
there's a there's a
there's about convergence to mass which
i really love of course
you've done a lot of work in that area
and i said like okay i removed the
elastic door underneath it now i have a
set of conditions when get chaotic
well is there okay like what's the next
nesting door what's the phase transition
that would make my chaotic result going
back to convergence okay so maybe this
is something that's like that's
currently let's say um
let's say uh on
unmodeled and let me tell you actually
what i'm looking at right now okay
so
what if okay
you actually create like an infinite
dimension measure
that actually encodes
a diversity of beliefs of the whole
population
so you know there are some people who
who right now they wake up and say like
look i'm going to go to the first part
of probably 20
another segment 21 22 23 the whole
real align from j1
so now the whole society is like
waveform
now this waveform gets updated
it's not just a single point right it's
a whole function
and now you see like okay
like so the so the current model is a
birac
you see like look everybody
thinks uniformly we wake up we have the
same beliefs we update and so forth
clearly artificial but a starting point
now you can say like okay what if
i don't do that
what if like no i allow
through diversity of beliefs and maybe
for example i allow
like uh
every you know a similar distribution
over the set of step sizes so like you
know you have step sizes from 0 to 100
now you have a fixed distribution there
you know
and then maybe i have another
distribution of a regularizer okay now
this looks like something like that
feels like look okay this is closer to a
real society
could it be the case that like okay this
system has like better
you know in that space of systems
actually equilibration is typical
and this dirac example was just
something like an artificial simplicity
again unfortunately and i kind of like
mean this it seems that it's not the
case
like our preliminary understanding of
this
i seem to suggest that like chaos is
exactly robust even in this infinite
dimensional case
but maybe there's a deeper
nesting goal you know
so like uh but i think uh
yeah but i think especially in problems
that we really try to
model something that we really feel
exists
out there like we should really be
trying to push
like yeah so i'm not looking at this and
say like okay this is something that
happens the real world
right now everything is kind of like a
mathematical curiosity i'm saying okay
look
how much do i believe in this
thank you very much everyone yeah so
there's gonna be two hour break and then
nika will start her tutorial on learning
and the prince of strategic behavior
see you then